Jaakko and echo question how important
is personal intelligence in the military
particularly in MO in more dangerous
roles as compared to physical strength
I'm a college student who will probably
go to OCS Officer Candidate School yeah
so this has been on my mind well okay so
intelligence is paramount right of
course if you aren't smart that you're
gonna do dumb things and dumb things can
definitely get you killed this is not to
say that if you do dumb things you will
get killed cuz I did some really dumb
things in combat and I didn't get killed
and it certainly isn't to say that if
you get killed you did something dumb
because to combat it has no mercy and
you can be the best trained the smartest
the most tackling sound person in the
world and those people can still get
killed the combat doesn't care about any
of that that bullet that has no one's
name on it it the bomb has no one's name
on it it's gonna go off and it's gonna
take out who it takes out and that's
that but as far as weighing you know
intelligence and cognitive power versus
strength I mean you have to be is I
would rather be smart and being
smartness is very important because if
you're smart if you aren't smart I
should say you you increase your chance
of doing something that isn't smart and
then you're gonna make some kind of a
mistake that will negatively impact you
so yes being smart is very important now
there are some cases without question
where physical strength and stamina is
at least as important and sometimes more
important that's just the way it is you
might have to climb a cliff to escape
the enemy but that's just the way it is
you might have to sue Mike Thornton Mike
Thornton swam for what five hours
dragging two people now he could be the
smartest guy in the world and which he
did a damn good job of just you know
getting the life jackets and getting
himself organizing a situation where
it'd be the easiest possible way for him
to swim even
that you still got to swim for five
hours dragging two people while you're
wounded by the way hmm
so if he didn't have that physical
strength at that point that brain
wouldn't matter it wouldn't matter so
what's interesting about this is guess
what a really smart person will get
himself or herself the physical
capabilities and that's what you'll do
and the smart person the really smart
person will work their ass off to get in
shape and into stay in shape
because you can be smart to come up with
the most brilliant plan in the world but
if you don't have the physical
wherewithal to execute that plan than
that that brilliant plan doesn't matter
so yes you want to be smart and yes you
want to be physically strong you want to
exercise your brain and your body as
much as possible and get them both as
mentally strong physically get yourself
as mentally strong as physically strong
as you possibly can and that's not just
in the not just in the military that's
in life in life somebody quoted on
Twitter the other day you if you - you
can't you don't know 2+2 if you're dead
like you can't add two plus there so if
you're if you're investing all your time
in being smart or you're investing all
your time and in that intellectual
aspect of your life and then you let
your physical aspect go yeah well guess
what now you're now you're unhealthy now
you died because you didn't take care of
you now what good is your brain now zero
zero good good check